was in den letzten wochen passiert ist
ist ja auch dass das vertrauen in die
regierungsfähigkeit der union schwindet
nach der flut bei anderen unglücklichen
oder schlechten entscheidungen macht ihr
in der zeuge naja es schwindet ein wenig
das vertrauen in regierungshandeln und
das ist nun mal nicht nur die union das
wonach sie soziales lernen ja aber sind
die mehreren rheinland pfalz sind wir
gar nicht in der regierung und auch
daran aber wir schauen auf den bund ja
wir schauen auf dem bund ist geglänzt
hat die regierung zahlen das ist war
strunz und das problem was wir im
augenblick haben ist dass wir so viele
krisen haben an so vielen orten der welt
und das vertrauen in die regierungen
insgesamt in allen großen westlichen
demokratien schwindet ob sie denn
überhaupt noch die lösung für diese
krisen haben und das muss sich in einer
demokratie jede regierung im grunde
genommen jeden tag neue arbeit nach
meiner erfahrung ist es immer das beste
zeichen des geschwächten und flachen
wenn er auf andere verweist ich verweise
ja nicht auf andere ich sagte 'ja wir es
ist für die demokratie insgesamt im
augenblick schwierig schauen sie nach
amerika die beiden frisch im amt
wird massiv angegriffen auch in seiner
eigenen partei
schauen sie nach frankreich makro ein
strahlender präsident mit großartigen
ergebnis gewählt hat große
schwierigkeiten seiner bevölkerung zu
vermitteln was er da gerade tut das ist
ein zeichen von ja schwächen von
demokratien in schwierigen zeiten die
schlagzeile heute lautet reisen müssen
geimpft getestet oder genesen sein wenn
sie noch bahn fahren wollen und es ist
auch die verursacherin dieser neuen
regel identifiziert frau merkel wie
bewerten sie diesen vorstoß der ja für
millionen pendler bedeutet dass sie
entweder nicht fahren können oder den
teuren test machen müssen also pleite
gehen also mich überrascht dass etwas
offenkundig nicht zufällig einen tag
nachdem der bundestag beschlossen hat
die pandemische lage zu verlängern
ich stelle mir trotzdem die frage auf
welcher rechtsgrundlage das denn
gefordert wird zweifeln sie das ist
rechtlich tatsächlich
geht und wenn es gehen würde hätte ich
große zweifel an der praktikabilität
stellen sie sich das mal vor millionen
pendler an den großen bahnhöfen hier in
berlin in köln in düsseldorf wo immer
sie hinschauen müssen morgens bevor sie
in den zug einsteigen getestet werden ob
sie gefragt werden und getestet werden
ob sie getestet genesen oder geimpft
sind also ich halte das für einige
verwicklungen gelähmt viele werden jetzt
zurückgelassen während wollen mit einem
fluglotsen live sprechen können in kabul
der auch der bundeswehr über viele jahre
geholfen hat er hat uns erzählt dass
keiner mal angerufen hat erstens war es
chaotisch man bekam keine vernünftigen
anweisungen wie sie jetzt rausgehen
können und als ich ihn gefragt habe ob
denn heute vielleicht mal jemand
angerufen hat und gefragt hat wie es
eben geht von irgendeiner institution
sei es bundeswehr botschaften sonstwas
nichts naja gut also wir haben ja nicht
nur den amerikanern zur seite gestanden
die amerikaner haben uns zur seite
gestanden und wir müssen ihnen leider
zugeben dass ohne die amerikaner selbst
diese evakuierungsmaßnahmen der letzten
tage nicht möglich gewesen wären und da
stellen sich für mich die eigentlichen
fragen sind wir noch nicht einmal in der
lage unsere soldatinnen soldaten unsere
staatsangehörigen und diejenigen die uns
geholfen haben in einer solchen
situation heil herauszukommen
was haben wir eigentlich für transport
kapazitäten in der bundeswehr wo sind
eigentlich die sicherungs einheiten die
wenigstens mal einen flughafen absichern
also wenn die deutsche bundeswehr noch
nicht einmal einen flughafen sichern
kann und in einer solchen notsituation
die eigenen staatsbürger evakuieren kann
stellen sich ganz andere fragen auch an
die verteidigungspolitik an die
sicherheitspolitik unseres landes und
die müssen wir beantworten
[Musik]